두 남자가 같은 날 비트코인 거래를
시작했습니다. 한 사람은 하루 12시간을
차트만 보며, 작은 초록 봉 하나도
놓치지 않으려 쫓아다녔습니다. 어젯밤, 단 한 번의
고래 함정에 그의 전 재산이 청산됐습니다. 반면
다른 남자는 가족과 저녁을 먹고,
편안히 잠든 뒤 아침에 일어나 보니
5,000달러의 수익이 나 있었습니다. 차이는
운이 아니었습니다. 시스템이었습니다. 한 사람은
사냥꾼이었고, 다른 한 사람은 방어자였습니다. 대부분의
트레이더가 실패하는 이유는 그들이
고래의 게임을 하기 때문입니다. 그들은 사라고 하면
사지만, 고래들은 이미 함정을 설치하고 있고
당신은 그들의 먹잇감입니다. Trap Defence BTC는
보이지 않는 것을 시각화함으로써
게임의 판도를 바꿉니다. 우리의 엔진은
기관의 조작을 미리 포착해
당신의 손익에 영향을 주기 전에 알려줍니다. 우리는
궁극의 트레이딩 스킬, 즉 확률이 당신 편이 될 때까지
안전하게 기다릴 수 있는 ‘규율’을 제공합니다.
이는 고위험 시장을 위한 고해상도 방어입니다.
그리고 오늘, 당신은 이 모든 것을
무료로 갖출 수 있습니다. 지금
Defenders Academy에 가입하고
Trap Score의 미니멀 에디션을
무료로 받으세요. 카드도 필요 없고, 군더더기도 없으며,
오직 시장의 날것 그대로의 진실만 제공합니다.
먹잇감이 되지 마세요. 방어자가 되십시오. 아래를 눌러
봇을 시작하고 당신의 무료
액세스를 지금 바로 받으세요.